we're going to start with
the
discussion portion
just to give a little context to the
reading that we've been doing
i am a big fan of
having designers
think about
uh
artifacts through the lens of criticism
uh every now and then
and
i have a background in
games criticism
uh i did that for about 10 weeks
in parallel with my industrious academic
career
when i was still in sweden
so
i also teach games criticism to
unrelated students here at mit
and
when it comes to how to
do critiques of the
interactive artifacts
there's
still
a lot of uncertainty about how to best
do it and
how and why it needs to be different
from criticism of film or literature or
any of these things that we've we've
been
doing analysis of four things forever
and one of the approaches is method
called interaction criticism
it's not specifically
designed for
games or playful interactive experiences
but just
interactive
non-uh
production related uh
artifacts in general
um
and
the text we've been reading today is one
from the originator himself
jeff parcell so we're trying to give an
introduction to
the method and the theory behind it
and the other one is him
and to other
uh interaction design and media studies
scholars
trying to apply interaction criticism to
a particular cultural artifact
uh
and uh
through different lenses and seeing what
they come up with and whether that's
interesting and fruitful
um so with that said let's start with uh
the one called interaction criticism and
introduction to the practice and put
keywords on the right
okay so
maybe
we want to start
with uh
it doesn't matter which one of these
it's over but uh
subjective
we'll put that there
okay hello okay so um
one of the
interesting things from this paper i
noticed is that you know when you talk
about criticism it's someone's judgment
on the thing and that judgment can often
be subjected and so a lot of the
discussion in this paper is reconciling
the
clearly subjective nature of criticism
but in a way that
they say is
judgments that are subjective but
non-perspective perspectival
i think they probably just made it
afterwards so it's your call
i know what they mean
um which ties into perspectives but the
idea is that you know the judgment
itself comes from
um
they focus on critics that are experts
in their fields and the judgments
themselves come from
experts who
know
about many similar um
like uh
types of interactions i would say i
don't want to say games because it
doesn't say games yeah no he clearly
sort of skirts
so
uh just just to
interrupt a little bit uh
specifically lev leno is one of the
people who are applying it in the second
paper i said that the only
professional practice of interaction
criticism is games criticism
uh we don't have any other sort of
interactive art form that's sort of
strong enough to have people get paid to
do this kind of criticism so for better
or worse
that's kind of what we have to look to
as an example but
um
especially barcelo i think is very
critical to how james cruz is currently
done
and thinks that there's a lot to learn
from other critical practices and he
comes from a background in
in
those
areas so
um
yeah that's he's not gonna talk about
games but they're sort of hovering in
there
mentions i guess also the
that they're not talking about amateur
critics like the people who go on amazon
or on steam and rate whatever they want
to rate um because that could be
subjective but very based on
like
that person's own experience without
trying to see things
so to begin with what what do we think
of this idea of
some
somehow more rigorous subjectivity
reflections are on that
yes
i put aesthetics and so it's kind of
it's very similar what we're talking
about right now
which um
i find that like
in
throughout the readings that we've been
doing like design is like in the middle
of
like science and art so
a lot of times there's like a temptation
to do things very scientifically but
like that fails when aesthetics come
into play because they're very
subjective
and so that's like that's why um we need
criticism like that's why that's what
the
father was kind of saying right so we
don't have the choice
but to rely on our subjectivity because
there's no other
rules given to us for how to evaluate
this kind of stuff
it's uh it's not
just describable that misses some
important point by the way i would say
that barcelo
doesn't think of design as something in
between
science and art but rather something
distinctly different from both
so he wants it to be its own thing
uh but yes clearly all
the sources that he is borrowing on when
he's creating this this method
come from one or the other so
so there's that yeah
uh
but yeah
yes i don't know those were the the the
sort of word pair i was thinking of when
i said we could start a need around but
then what goes into this expertise that
he talks about how do we justify that
someone's
subjective opinion of something is more
ways heavier than someone else's what's
the what makes up for the difference
between
uh a
critic and someone on
amazon full knowledge about the field
and being having
a very broad experience and i guess the
people who you're critiquing who are
reading the critiques knowing that you
have that broad experience
someone that got an espresso machine off
amazon might leave a terrible review
being like oh it did it didn't just
instantly make me coffee one star
because they don't understand how the
espresso machine works or like what the
different like grades might be or how
any of the different pieces of the
process work whereas
the critic who will have value behind
what they say understands the whole
field and how this helps what place it
has and what the context of it and like
other good works in the field are right
so good examples this is one of those
things that are often highlighted in
design education so i probably have said
the word a couple of times during the
semester as well so
the way
we educate ourselves in design is often
looking at what has been established as
good examples
and they're good just because someone
decided they were good there's nothing
in nature determining that they're good
other than ourselves and our community
but
that's
that that has an important role i would
say within games criticism
there's nothing that
speaks as loud as having this almost
data based knowledge of the history of
video games when you get interviewed for
writing for a website or a
journal or something magazine i should
say
that's what they question you on like do
you know about this and that and
that is
the most important criteria for whether
you're going to get the job or not
uh
do you know the history yes
and that is one of the things that
barcelo would say is the problem with
games criticism what do you think could
be potentially an issue with
that kind of filter for who gets to be a
critic
right but yeah they actually expect you
to not just know it but have played it
so
the most well played if we can use make
up a word based on well read um so the
most well-played people tend to get the
the jobs as critics but is there a
problem with that
and what would that be we're never sort
of off the paper already but we'll get
back there
there's sort of a disconnect between
someone who has played a lot of games
and someone who has played no games
yes
yes
but
yes well i mean it's all it would be
difficult for the folks who've played
a lot of games to be able to even
translate
their thoughts to someone who's never
played
like those
that's gameplay you were saying
right so yes
uh you will be
a little bit like let's say a jazz
critic that just listens to a
culture yeah well not even co-training
is for the masses
they're beyond culture
uh
they might be
talking about the heads of most people
so there's a disconnect with the
audience that's so that might just make
the criticism very insular
and
not
really sort of reach the audience who
might be interested in
evaluation of these cultural artifacts
so that's i think it's a very
uh very good point
anything else along those lines
so what a
fix to to accommodate for that these do
you like
for a writing sample and actually judge
whether or not that person can
communicate to
people at multiple levels of an audience
actually the most important skill is not
being a very knowledgeable gamer but
being a good writer because
um
without that skill you you get nowhere
and
no one's going to read you basically
because you write like like a robot or
something
actually i want to say even the the
converse
might actually be true of trying to look
for people who don't sort of hold the
line of traditional gameplay
[Music]
so folks who
are expressly
stating
opinions from or
or analyzing games that are coming out
uh
from the lengths of something that's not
like traditional games crazy that
seems in this
click
hungry media landscape seems actually um
to be a lot more interesting to read
right so the good writers and they're
bringing a new perspective
and i think
for among other things
one important reason is that there is
an existing hegemony
around the field of what
a good game is
should be that may be
based on
assumptions about
gender and culture that should be
questioned
it might be white men writing for white
men basically of a certain age
and if we think especially back in time
uh
playing video games having grown up
playing all these games on all these
consoles implies a very strong privilege
when it comes to
finance your family's finances for
instance consoles used to be
i mean they used to cost the same as
they cost today games used to cost the
same as they cost today but that was a
lot more money
in the 80s and 90s than it is now so
someone who had access to all of the
existing home consoles were probably a
rich game yeah so those were the ones
who became reviewers and decided what a
good thing so
there's something about you know looking
to those good examples that could also
needs some questioning and we might
need to break with those traditions and
look at
other potential values in interactive
artifacts as the ones that we are
creating
those that are maybe more inclusive or
taking other
skill sets uh too hard rather than just
you know
excellent hand-eye coordination or
whatever it is that makes you a good
gamer
if you were expressly looking for people
who
state that they have a long
history with games
and can bring out this catalog like
which
which history
right because it's games or even digital
games
okay extend that out to non-digital
games to include board games and
tabletop and sports then it's like each
country each
region has its own history and people
consider different things canonical
so you know a lot of american
white men writing for white for for
white boys
pretty much
you know have a fairly lacking
experience of
eastern block games um you know even
games that were released in asia for
instance um only the few japanese games
are sort of like a really recent america
and they think that's all of japan right
and it's like no that's not yeah that's
that's part of japan and not even all of
asia yeah so so that would be an example
that would be another problem is that
you assume that a long history implies a
comprehensive history but no one really
has a comprehensive
history with the entire world's
history of kings yes and that criticism
has
been being
uh
put towards
design studies as well i mean we are
reading three white men of his somewhat
certain age
uh here today so
they are to some extent
myopic as well when it comes to
cultural values in these uh
in these artifacts and
i was thinking maybe we can get back on
track by
uh
inviting whoever put perspectives uh on
there
yeah they were talking in
this article about
like the four perspectives of like
was it um the designer
the um
user
were they
like the artifact
it was sort of what i was talking about
before it's like someone who is very
well played is going to have a different
interaction with the artifact but
compared to someone who does not play a
lot of games just you have to consider a
lot of different perspectives and it's
very easy to get stuck in and the idea
is
you are like get stuck in one
like a creator can't see their own
problems a lot of the time which is why
you need criticism right and the
criticizer doesn't have the perspective
that the um
creator does
so that's i mean that's one one of the
reason we have criticism is to try to
improve whatever field we are critiquing
so
it's supposed to be a help for the
designers to see things that they can't
see themselves as well
what i would do if this was a
longer class i would have you write up
critiques of each other's work but we're
just we have so much work to do so we
don't quite have time for it so i don't
want to
sort of burden you with that but it is a
very interesting exercise because
you
instantly see that people see things in
the thing you've been making that you
didn't see yourself and you thought you
saw all of it because you're so engaged
this is also
something that
breaks with tradition of
old school
literary theory which
used to be very heavily focused on
artifacts so
you
wanted to just look at the text and see
what the meaning of the text really is
it comes from religious studies of
trying to figure out you know what the
bible is telling us to do or something
like that
uh but that was what the academic study
of literature used to be as well what
uh
is the author's intentions with this
text and try to sort of just reverse
engineer that
nowadays
we read and we can talk about
all kinds of artifacts as texts it seems
a little weird to do that called the
game of text for instance but if you
think of the latin uh
origin of the word which textedit makes
it
means more like a texture like something
that's woven together then it's easier
to think talk and think about
things as texts other than written words
on a page
so
when we interpret texts now
we through interaction criticism for
instance we very much take into account
the
context it is used in because we think
that there isn't just one meaning of a
cultural artifact it actually changes
meaning depending on who is interacting
with it and under which circumstances so
and that is something that has
changed
literature studies as well the the
the the idea of um
it being someone encountering the text
which you can hear in the name of
reader response theory for instance
which is it's not
just about what
shakespeare meant when he wrote the text
it's about how a reader now can respond
to a text like hamlet that that is of
interest so
this is very much
based on that traditional
we are doing a reading
not just all the artifact itself but
the context of use and the the
identity of the the use right so
okay so what you have left
let's balance let's talk about a little
bit about balance
um
so i put out that up there and it was
mostly about um
he was talking about how
with the criticisms there's some
somewhat of trying to strike this
balance and uh
with the between like historical context
uh cultural significance and being like
technical descriptions and like
um how do you so how do you balance the
the different elements that you should
be looking at because these are all
different lenses that a different person
might evaluate through differently
especially based on what field they're
in that is not
interaction design interaction criticism
for design but like scientific design is
very much of the how this was done or
chris and how this was done empirical
facts
um
and so there's a lot about
different ways to
focus those designs uh to focus the
criticism based on
um
the
different aspects that you can be trying
to evaluate through
and that is what
i think for parts of that is one of the
things that
creates the need for interaction
criticism because that's
somewhat alien to someone who is doing
criticism of movies or literature
to them it's perfectly fine to look at
it
as
just something that that is
being
evaluated for its aesthetics
and the story
well when we evaluate the game
let's say you're driving a car in the
game and the steering works very poorly
it's just there's a usability issue
there that's very similar to when we
evaluate
cars
uh
so
if
if the steering is bad that's gonna
affect the quality of this kind of
artwork thing but it's a very sort of
usability center thing so
games and interactive artifacts live in
this weird space where these things come
together and all of them matter so some
of it is just matter of fact like
this
this steering wheel is bad
uh
well while some of it is like
the the
the scenery of the car ride in this game
evokes
emotions
so
it to me it's what makes
uh interaction design cool
because it has all of these very
different
qualities to it and
and
they can be foregrounded or or or
sort of be more part of the periphery
but
they all have to work in concert for an
interaction design for the unity or
organic unity of it those parcels has to
to
click
okay so i guess we just have framework
so let's do that one as well so you
don't feel that
yeah i put framework because
this article is like a lot about
developing
like a way to criticize interactive
material and like
i think um
it mentions how like
it's about developing skills that enable
people to think
about um
interaction
and so
that's why i thought pretty much was a
good way right
yeah i mean that's
that's what he's he's doing here so
uh it's a somewhat ambitious project to
to establish
being starting the establishment of a
framework that goes outside of the
traditional hci which is much more
usability focused and and without losing
those qualities still
capturing the things that sort of
fall through the
uh the net of what what that type of
criticism or that type of evaluation
captures in an experience
okay are you ready
for uh
paper number two looking at the actual
application of interaction creation
yes what's the difference um
so
there are
practical there are car critics right
there yes people who review cars
professionally yes
what's the difference
would that be considered a form of
uh
criticism
right so
i i think
that to board cell it doesn't
it's not no okay it's because the focus
is so much on the usability aspects not
unlike
the interiors
right i mean
yes we we do sometimes see that kind of
approach where someone is sort of trying
to focus more on the experience of a car
or
something like that and that's when it
starts coming closer to that line so he
he he talks about not in this paper but
in another
sort of parallel paper he talks about
interior design and things like that
that there's definitely touch points and
when we start talking about stuff like
the sound design of you know what sound
the corridor makes when it closes
that's very carefully designed nowadays
and that is part of the ecstatic
experience so it's like
going back to balance there could be
like uh
two-dimensional one-conventional might
be too too few dimensions but like
there's aesthetics on one side and like
usability
technical details on the other and like
car critics fall much closer to the
technical usability side interior design
falls much more towards the aesthetic
side
right
but it's terrible science maybe it's not
aligned because interior design is
in interior design critique is still
very far from
traditional literary theory okay
so maybe it's
some kind of
weird polygon i don't think it's even a
triangle
but but yeah it's a field where he
sort of tries to
um
[Music]
visualize some of the
oh yeah
right
but but maybe not maybe not necessarily
like all of them i don't think he tries
to be comprehensive of what that space
looks like but
it's i think i feel like the paper is
still written as the critique of hdi
studies so if that's the one he wants to
focus on like you guys are missing
things when
when when you decide what gets accepted
to kai or something but that's the
context of where he's publishing it
right he's
interacting with computers and partners
uh as the magazine yeah it is the
journal
um
and and i'm curious about that other
people that you're describing because
you're talking about your design i'm
thinking there's got to be
architectural criticism that's a fairly
well established field
and right the only difference
that i see between what he's arguing and
architectural criticism is
the use of computers in his right what's
he describing you know we're talking
about concrete and steel and
wood and other kinds of materials but
all everything else
architectures are just as interactive as
anything built-in right
the
uh the outside of academia
uh professional core of architectural
critics is very small though
so i don't think it reaches so it was
levianous that is only the
games that really have an established
core of professional critics outside of
academia
and i think it means he's thinking that
the architectural critics of machine
i mean that's that's perfectly fine
right so to argue that it should be a
larger right so
and i also think that
when we look towards
architecture we're also seeing this
transition where
where they try to focus more on
experience
and
different perspectives rather than
saying that the quality of the
architecture is in the artifact itself
it used to be if you look at
architecture education
the good examples was very much about
like
this is good because this and this and
this rather than talking about it's good
from this perspective
because
so
um there is that movement within
architectural criticism as well to
go maybe
i usually have architecture students in
like the other classes and they always
giggle when i mention gary because
within architecture he's seen as
kind of a fad and
we have a
big wonky example of that here on campus
so
so that sort of focus on the beautiful
shapes and all of that is
it's a little old school now in
architecture and now it's more about
this how livable is this or how you know
how well can you work in that weird
bubble and
it turns out not very well because
it's just as literary criticism and no
doubt interactive design criticism is
going to go through these
these waves right of different styles of
criticism and
they don't invalidate the old ones they
just add to how we look at the same the
same one right but they might invalidate
decisions to
hire certain architects to do certain
flagship buildings on campus or
something like that i don't think that
choice would be my
based on criticism yeah well based on uh
sort of oh yeah that was maybe cool
because
the methods were
new
and they're not so new anymore so
yeah it's a little bit of that hype
thing has gone away from
oh we can actually
have computers
design curves that we couldn't calculate
before if they would be you know
load-bearing
so certainly mit because we have an
architecture department and architecture
faculty
criticism must influence the choice of
architects yeah yeah i mean i think
for one thing the mit campus has a lot
more examples of
high
profile architectural
drawn buildings than almost any other
campus because we have such a
prominent architecture department
uh and
through a series of styles that don't
necessarily always fit together they
they don't you don't
the scrapbook yeah it's very much
anyway that's a little bit of a tangent
to you so
uh
any other
thoughts on
on the versailles paper though before we
leave
it's very good okay now let's let's do
keywords for this
okay so i'm tempted to
we
we had perspectives in the last paper
and now we have lenses so maybe we can
start with lenses and they can uh just
grab what the difference between a lens
and a prism um so i specifically said
lenses because perspectives can mean
like you know personal perspectives like
you might have a very different
perspective of the game than i do
because of our personal like backgrounds
and likes and whatnot but the lenses are
more you're doing this through
a performance-based lens you're viewing
this through an interaction-based lens
you're viewing this
through the context of a particular
thing not through the cons so it's
perspectives can be that but it can also
be through yourself
or through how a user or like how
through certain people might feel which
is why i specifically said lenses right
yeah and i think yeah that's that's spot
on what they mean as well it's more like
i as a person choose to put on this lens
a little bit like you might switch the
lens for your camera for a particular
purpose
okay so what um uh did you have more to
say about your
your word
yeah so
like a big one of the big like things
that he's talking about in this paper is
how
through different lenses the same thing
can be viewed in like very different
lights or very different ways really
come out very differently in the
criticism
um so he has like you know the the three
different
criticism points of maeve and his saying
at the end about
um how just because of these lenses the
criticism of
the intel of like either they like the
interaction
the performance or the users um comes
through differently
yeah i think we should be able to jump
to
almost any of the words from there let's
uh
let's
maybe do
interface first
okay so um
one of my favorite sentences in this
article is uh that
form and content in from interface and
information are inseparable
and this
interfaces is how describes how you
interact with
the
information that's being presented to
you and can greatly influence how you
interpret the information that is
presented to you
they use
as an example
the um i think it was like a java applet
the the word synonym finder this visual
synonym finder
i actually have a memory of using this
way back in the in the day the early
internet days of having it like this
bubble on the screen and
um
well earlier
worldwide websites yeah
the internet is very wrong
that's true excuse me that is what i
meant
back in the days when dial-up was a
thing
um
so that i remembered that experience and
so that was uh
the way that they frame it is
um that experience of seeing words and
connection to other words and how they
relate to each other and being able to
make these hops these may be small pops
but end up very far away from the word
that you started makes language more
fluid instead of like when you read a
dictionary which has basically the same
information it contains words and what
they mean
but it's presented in this very logical
strict manner um and similarly with um
this mave project you can think of it as
oh you just have a collection of files
on different i think it's like an
architectural
um this architectural project
um
and you could like click through the
files or something have it on your
computer screen but now they've turned
it into
basically the
users of the system are performers what
they choose to view gets presented on a
larger screen
and they also get to see
how
their
like the cards that they choose relate
to things that other users are choosing
and this adds like a social element a
performative element
and greatly
changes the way
users can see how each of these
different
cards
are like they can actually see more
direct comparisons
so
yeah okay
no no
yeah that's a pretty
powerful idea i think that it's not just
sort of a
quantitative difference between
different
interfaces like another example would be
like the
the physical typewriter
versus a word processor it's not just
that the word poses or makes it
easier or faster to produce text we
actually write different things
we think differently because of this
word processor working in a certain way
than we used to think when we had
typewriters it's somehow changed
the world and not just you know
again quantitatively but but
qualitatively
people
understand
texts and themselves differently because
of this change of
interface
and this is just a
an extension of that where we can
understand
uh another data set
completely differently depending on how
it is not just presented to us but how
we are allowed to interact with it
[Music]
we will get back a little bit to
the idea of
being able to interacting with ideas
next week when we're going to start
thinking about how to disseminate the
knowledge that we're generating in this
class but
i'll leave that
there for now
um
i'm just going to keep going here
distinction
that was me
the article was talking a lot about how
increasingly we're
splitting like form and function
and the idea is like
the information you want to convey to
the user and the way that you do that
are considered differently and
that's not a good thing
it's like the idea of using the
like lenses in the interface the stuff
we've been talking about
to
mix the two because it's often more
successful like
you want to get the
like i'm just going to use a video game
like you want to get plot information
across to the
player because it's a story but you also
want them to have like fun while doing
it and interact with the story
so it's like they were talking about the
idea of
um performative experiences
yeah
um
that goes very much along the
same lines of what we were talking about
with the interfaces i think
uh
let's keep on going the information
yeah
um the reason i put that down was also
because
of the way um the paper said that
interface and information are
inseparable it's not as you're all
caught on to the same
i guess that is the big takeaway from
from this paper
uh and it's
it's all i think the same sort of
criticism of
maybe specifically in software
engineering we before
for
reasons of dealing with complexity we
divided different aspects of these
artifacts into different roles in
different teams and it turns out it's
kind of a sub-optimization because
it all has to
work in concert or
it's not going to be successful and sort
of
trying to
find a way back to
uh
ideas of the the designer and the the
the one actually manufacturing something
being the same person where they you
know have full control over all aspects
of it to how can we
how can we have
complex uh development with
a lot of people involved and still not
lose
touch of the organic
unity of the thing how it all relates to
to each other
did performance have anything
else to add that hasn't come up already
i feel like we're beating this to
to the ground
or information
yes yes
if there was something that you felt
hasn't been
well i guess
we didn't talk about like the
communication aspect
that was in the paper
like about how
um
the users in the loop of like
application
but also now with like social media
you're also communicating things to
other people
and and performance
um
i don't know if i have much more to add
but
uh but i just thought it was really
interesting because i
release what i'm designing i think of my
users like in a vacuum kind of or
something if it's like a multi-player
experience then i think of them working
together but like i had never thought of
someone being performant or
as a user right and so i just thought
that was interesting
like an interesting takeaway for me and
my design
endeavors right
i i don't think it's just
pointing towards the importance of
user testing but also
trying to challenge your own assumptions
as you're
having people test your your artifact
again we're it's the the things we
create are or
our babies and we tend to sort of
uh cradle them a little sort of hard
sometimes and we don't want we want
people to
get how we intended them to be used and
then we might be less open to seeing
where
where
the the users or the participants
actually
subvert our intentions but still make
interesting use of the artifacts and
that is something that we could actually
benefit from from
from allowing and allowing ourselves to
see
[Music]
and i think
one just one example was when i was
um
talking to game designers here in boston
about
designing co-op games and i was making a
case that they often make a less
interesting experience for player two
than for player one
uh i had a guy come up to me afterwards
saying i've made co-op games for 10
years
and never thought of myself as anything
other than player one
so you know if you're making those kinds
of
experiences at least try out the
different roles that you're designing
for just
not make assumptions that well the
expert or the highly skilled person is
always going to be in this role and that
fits me so
i'm always going to try out that role
because
when you try out
the role of player 2 you might find that
it's much less fun or interesting
than you intended it for it to be just
as
one brief example
i also found it really interesting how
they connected performance to social
media um platforms because that is an
interactive experience that isn't a game
yeah uh some people think it's a game um
how many likes do you have yeah it can
be games for sure yeah or or like world
of warcraft where you create this
alternate persona where you put on this
you perform you perform the role of
night elf
priest or whatever or
you perform the role of
a popular figure on twitter who talks
about
puppies
um and that sort of thing and i thought
i hadn't thought of it as performance
before but it
immediately comes down to that and
depending on how
much community
aspect you have inside of your whatever
you're developing
it seems like there's more of a
performance
yeah it's
there's a lot of
opportunity for designing
your own role or identity online
than you have in
offline performance i mean we're still
performing a certain role when we're at
work or versus at home and so on but but
you have a lot more
variables to tweak i think online and
it's just something that's
inherently new it's not something that
we have any experience from
before this
century we just didn't have
massively
multi-experienced virtual environments
and now we do so we're struggling a
little bit with how to
design for them and make sense of them
but it's
no one else is going to do it for us so
you are the ones to to
to solve these issues congratulations